l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono parigi oggi siano sul gioco
un pochettino diverso si chiama
guardians of member che in italiano dire
i guardiani della brace delle grigliate
let's go piane ed aurora d'aurora
perfezionati aurora studiano e non lo
tocchiamo volevo dirvi che il gioco che
lo lascio nella descrizione è molto
molto carino ci sono i goblin i sicuri
però sono livello 3 aspetta che io sono
io e lo scarso aiutami a lyndon grazie
lindo aspetta mi riguarda è qua che vi
questo mi serve solo un livello troppo
basso
non va bene dammi una mano signore lindo
miglior amarok è un casino qua grazie
grazie
mamma mia che amico mi sono fatto sta
che me lo invito mamma mia ma lei è
fantastico ma lei è un fenomeno ma lei
un livello altissimo a che livello è
questo cristiano guai in qualità di
guardiano dell'eber devo sconfiggere la
minaccia oscura e concludere la guerra
ad ora in the u all inter non sono
sicuro bene di come si dica holding del
prova basta a seguirmi che fastidio è
neanche le guardie della città mi
difendono mi difenda un uomo comandante
guardia dei confini mi difenda e ci ha
pensato giovanni va bene lo stesso uno
che accetta un duello uno che accetta il
duello pence signor pensa cento grazie
accettato venga qui signor princi
gli attacchi gli attacchi aiuto ai ma fa
malissimo nei duelli ragazzi non ci si
può curare e maleducazione nei duelli
contro la gente online curarsi quindi
non posso curarmi con le forze scusatemi
non si fa mai e non lo farò
è un duello tra tra fortissimi finisci
domani su duello c'è come che lui con
una botta mileva 12 e io gli devo 1
aiuto
scarso player party with mi vedesse
qualcuno risponde vi prego dell'interno
ha sbloccato ha visto che sono talmente
scarso che ha detto vabbè lasciamo
perdere
my friend the west ham iii ha scritto
sesso l'italiano si lo sono perfetto o
ho tratto l'italiano meno male va bè
ragazzi allora devo assolutamente questa
aree con lui
fortunatamente ho trovato un amico
fidato allora lui è un sacerdote mi sa
sono quattro razze se i classici sono un
totale di 300 abilità quindi va beh per
scoprire tutto finiamo tra una vita
amico però dammi una mano sono schiatto
mi da bravo bravo mamma mia quanta gente
vuole farmi fuori
vi prego aiutami gran casino posso usare
le forze battista quanti sperano mamma
mia ovviamente tante fissa cui
equipaggiato l'arma più giusta porca
vacca se devo di più è fratello fratello
mista mi spiace mi sa che non aveva
l'arma giusta questa mia aumentato un
sacco di danni da allevare 1 adesso 40 e
non c'è più gente che sfiga per
curiosità ridurle chiamo un secondo
prova a vedere adesso come fratello
prova ci vai
e adesso adesso mi sa che c'è un attimo
più di più di competizione rispetto a
prima potrebbe darsi che vinco non è
detto
hai anche male
mamma mia che stiamo contenendo un sacco
aiuto fresco attenzione presto il
vincitore e quasi quasi ma perché non
mischiamo che perfetto fratello fratello
a chi o insegnare a giocare anche
l'insegnante c'è stata questa
ho capito solo che doveva pagare gli
oggetti giusti no è morto è morto
la cina era te l'ho lasciata po capitani
due linee ammazza la gente solo che poi
l'hanno ucciso i goblin ai ragazzi
ognuno per in avanti vorrei arrivare un
sacco avanti perché non ovviamente
questo video però in generale se ci
gioco anche per i fatti miei quindi
questo gioco qua puoi avere poi la tua
casa è tutto è veramente una figata
ve lo lascio anche in descrizione
comunque come ho detto prima eccolo
vista che dobbiamo fare fuori canc a
signorini che perfetto grazie ai seggi
ti devi muovere se no ti spaccano
fratello signor tesi si muovo palco è
successo ed è rimasto lì sarà
contemplando e alla sua sconfitta sarà
ancora edifici a digerirla sto
scherzando che chissà quando vedrà
questo video cosa pensa porzione della
salute umile umile non se la tira questa
porzione la prendiamo un altro dato una
nuova skin mi sa che posso piazzare
trappole può essere e quello se posso
pensare alle trappole se ci finiscono
sopra nemici o si rallentano pure
rifanno davano non lo so siamo avanti
per i cavoli i nostri a conquistare il
mondo un signor pescatore buongiorno
fate silenzio fate scappare i pesci ma
per favore intruso non deve uscire viola
orca vacca aiuto e sperma devo far fuori
mamma mia che casino
faccio un tizio grossissimo lì quello
non lo faccio pure io spero facciano
revisione del mio amico che però se n'è
andato questo tizio era un assaggio
della mia forza mi sa che devo far fuori
quello che lo tiene imprigionato può
essere
non è vero si è mosso bob abili a
ragazzina è questo e un po grosso
bilancio una trappola
no scherzo al bando la preso ma non si è
fatto niente premorto perché sono
fortissimo non è morto scherzavo amico
dammi la mano bravo bravissimo
c'è un amico che milano ma eccolo grazie
grazie non è fosse stato per te a
livello 8 un pochettino ci aveva nel
quadrante di prova niente dai ragazzi mi
sa che quei mostri sono aumentati
livello sono più forti di prima
e io avrei bisogno di andare al prossimo
avamposto per vedersi incontro gente un
po più forte devo liberare dai gobbi
sono troppo giovane per morire ma cosa
dici dei bruttissimi poi bello che ti
menano come se niente fosse dicono sono
troppo giovane per morire va bene tanto
questa roba qua ok mail on a questo poi
quando ti mandano la mail grossa
signoria gerra venga venga invito al
gruppo doveva scrivere in basso a lingua
anche se non sorpreso scritto suo pit mi
sta chiedendo se parla la sua lingua per
uno ecco esattamente mi ha scritto
questo è solo il giovedì ecco adesso
secondo me ha capito è esatto invitato
lei gruppo bellissimo ha capito solo
giovedì
io l'aiuto a fare una questa signorina
gerra ma in un cielo questa questa la
palla faccio perché le voglio bene
il cibo ora spetta sapete che c'è un
tizio era roma da battere nel it's ok è
forte la zia paolo cia dei danni ad area
pazzeschi ma ci sarà un boss alla fine
di sposino qualcosa regalo speciale
grazie che se lo prendo il regalo questo
perché ti voglio bene
no l'ho buttato smetterò mio zio e zia
guerra che questo che ci fa danno cioè
moriamo ragazzi moriamo e pazza lati per
forza è andata in mezzo allo schifo
al tipo non lo puoi far fuori di far
prima presenza di truppe ok il momento
via via è forte devi darmi la magia è
forte è forte di spaccarlo brava brava
spacca lo spacco io sto stancando
dammi la mano per non farmi fare da solo
che un casino perfetto va bene è un
dungeon questo abbiamo fatto un dungeon
quindi dai ragazzi questo è l'ultimo gf
sarà l'episodio di guardians of m però
che vi sia piaciuto
spero di non aver ferito i sentimenti
del mio amico italiano perché una certa
andato via
la tipa continua sussurrarmi frasi in
russo io non me lo faccio vedere tanto
non ci avete capito niente
ma neanche io mi sia piaciuto vi lascio
il link per provare il gioco in
descrizione noi come sempre ci vediamo
un proseguito schiacciato il tasto
iscriviti e la campanella prima giornata
sul vivido e non ci vediamo come sempre
ai ragazzi
[Musica]
ma